The wonderful thing about My Little Ponies
is they live forever!
Whee! (cheery music)
If only bronies did as well.
(heavy breathing)
(Unknown Speaker) I'm a pony!
(somber music)
When it comes to burial options,
only one choice makes sense for a lifelong brony:
donate your body to the Brony Glue Factory!
At the Brony Glue Factory,
we honor your dedication to the world of make believe.
While your spirit frolics in the meadows of equestria,
your lifeless body joins dozens of other bronies
in a brand new adventure.
Your brony remains get dipped in a high temperature enzyme
that dissolves your flesh and bones
and renders you into a powerful adhesive.
(glue pouring)
The same adhesive that's used
to make the next generation of My Little Pony toys,
so you can literally be a part of them forever.
Bro-nate your body to the Brony Glue Factory today!
♫ Your dreams come true, we get free glue.
(audience laughs)
That's right.
That's right. That guy died.
All right.
(laughs)